so the next talk is by the same authors
but this one time it will be presented
by Marc Marc Howard and it's application
of a resource theory for magic States to
fault-tolerant quantum computation
okay thanks lush this is work with RL
who you might remember from 60 seconds
ago so we're going to apply a resource
theory to the setting of fault tolerant
computation so I'll spend a couple of
slides just on motivating and getting
some background so the cartoon picture
of how we're going to build a quantum
computer is we're going to use an error
correcting code which is going to take
some data use some encoding circuit to
spread it out over multiple physical
qubits then we're going to operate on
our data and maybe suffer some noise
we're gonna perform measurements and
they're going to maybe inform our
decision on some correction operation
that we do and then at the end of the
day we've applied some logical unitary
to our encrypted or encoded data so
that's the plan stabilizer codes are the
family of codes that we understand the
best and naturally associated with them
are they differ groups so we've already
seen that twice today so clipper group
is generated by C not Hadamard and S
which is the square root of the Z
rotation about the z axis or I like to
think of it as the group generated by
the C naught and the set of rotations
that map the octahedron inside the Bloch
sphere onto itself so the encoding
circuit is typically tifford that's fine
but a lot of times what you find is that
the gates that you can do the logical
gates that you can do in a
fault-tolerant way are also covered and
that's not great news
so the more precise statement is that
you can't get a transversal and
Universal set of gates within within an
area correcting code and so you have to
come up with some other idea and you
know we have in mind as a neural stuff
that the Torah code or something like
that so how are we going to get around
that we're going to just add to the
gates that we can do we're going to add
a supply of magic States so what is the
magic state it's a state that enables an
on clifford gate so T state as we saw in
the last talk
so here's what it looks like
geometrically on the left so as I said
before we have the octahedron inside the
Bloch sphere that's this object with six
vertices so I think of Paul the x y&z
you're three poly operators each of them
as two eigenstates so that forms six
fewer states on the point of the on the
surface of the Bloch sphere and then if
you join them together that makes an
octahedron so the T State is obviously
it has to be outside this octahedron
it's not a stabilizer state and it lies
somewhere between the X eigenstate and Y
eigenstate so what's good about the T
state is that we can just take a copy of
it form this different circuit and then
that gives us effectively DT gauge which
we want
so just reiterate yeah if we have the
Clifford group just a bit here you don't
get universal quantum computing but you
have the Clifford group and then you add
in the Stiga you do get a universal
quantum computing capability so how do
you actually get access to these T
States well you can't just create them
perfectly straight off the bat so best
you can hope to do is create bad
versions of them and then it'll
iteratively improve those until they get
purer and purer so in circus form what
you do is you take in multiple copies of
a noisy T state form some measurements
and then as they're all said if you get
the wrong answer just throw it away you
get the right answer you have an encoded
version of your T State that you want
and then so just on encode now you have
your T State so you might have to do
this multiple times and so this is the
circuit picture and what you should have
in your mind is that this really tedious
process the meat grinder where you put
in you know lots of bad stuff at the top
and you crank the handle for a long time
and eventually get out some nice shiny
thing at the end and you want to you
know avoid doing that as much as much as
possible so the overhead associated with
the magic state distillation is actually
polynomial in the number of T gates so
it's efficient in the computer science
sense but when you actually run the
numbers they're kind of eye watering so
logical clifford's account for two to
ten percent and the logical non
clifford's if you include this machinery
associated with magic state distillation
can account for over 90%
so I think there's a lot of interesting
work to be done in this middle ground
between okay people in labs building
high quality qubits people in ivory
towers inventing quantum algorithms and
then in between here we're trying to you
know connect all these qubits up to make
a useful device and we want to do it in
a way that doesn't use billions of
qubits if possible we can maybe try and
get that down to by a couple of orders
of magnitude just by having some good
ideas so just last comment just to
reiterate that it seemed my team kind of
weird when you first see it that you can
do these z axis rotations you can do the
Z rotation and the S rotation which is
just kind of a quarter of the way around
the block sphere you can do that easily
but the T gate which is just a 1/8
rotation around the z axis is hard you
say okay why don't you just leave your
laser on for half as long but it's
because you're working at the encoded
level okay so that's why you have these
extra restrictions that make the T gets
harder okay so now we have this natural
partition in two easy and hard stuff so
in our case the easy stuff is going to
be the stabilizer or / Clifford stuff
the hard stuff is going to be the Qi
gates and the sociated things so this
suggests that cannot looking at this in
terms of a resource theory so Reiser
theories have been very successful in
kind of information theory and cartoon
pictures that you have some set of free
States or cheap stuff and then outside
of that you have the expensive stuff and
so if I take some one expensive thing
how do i quantify how expensive it is
well robustness is a very good
quantifier so the idea is that you
decompose your expensive thing in terms
of the free stuff so there's going to be
some free stage far away from our
expensive state and as I mix the free
thing with the expensive thing the
expensive thing gets pushed further and
further honey eventually it gets into
the region of free stuff and so this is
essentially captured by robustness which
I have here so that I captured the
amount of mixing that's required
obviously there are different
decompositions that you could pick and
so this is kind of the minimum over all
possible decompositions so as I said
that's the kind of generic thing and
robustness appears in you know
entanglement and all sorts of other
resource theories and so in our case
it's gonna be the free stuff is going to
be stabilizer stuff and the expensive
stuff is going to be non stabilizer
stuff and then the region of free stuff
is going to be the stabilizer pollito so
the generalization of they octahedron
that I showed before so you want to have
your quantifier to obey certain
reasonable things to be useful and we've
shown it for this stabilizer resource
theory other people have shown it for
the other ones so what you want
something like faithfulness so that the
robustness of a state inside this free
region is one and everything outside it
has robustness greater than one it also
obeys some multiplicative 'ti so if you
take two copies of the state and look at
the robustness that's going to be less
than or equal to the robustness of that
state squared and then it's not
increasing under stabilizer operations
so it's monotonic so overall that's a
well-behaved quantifier some people
would prefer that you could just take
the log of this quantity that we've
defined and then you'd find that the
kind of baseline level is zero and so
multiplicatively becomes subadditivity
that's just personal preference
okay so now we had the cartoon kind of
geometric picture how do you actually
calculate robustness if I if you give me
a state how do I calculate the number
associated with the robustness so you
recast it as a linear program which
looks like this so that the problem
statement is I have some matrix a and
some matrix B and I'm trying to find the
best vector X so matrix a is going to
describe the vertices of this region of
free States matrix vector B is going to
be a representation of my resource state
and X is some decomposition of the
vertices of the free thing which gives
me B but this this problem as it stated
here is under determined so there are
lots of different X's which will satisfy
this equation so I want to find the one
that has minimum l1 norm okay so a
concrete example is going back to this
just a single T State for a single qubit
the a matrix has got six columns because
there are six stabilizer States on and
the vertices of this octahedron so the
zero state is just this column here
which has got one expectation value for
Sigma Z and so on my T State here is
going to have a B vector that looks like
this so it's got 1 over root 2 Sigma X
coefficient 1 over root 2 Sigma Y
coefficient and 0 Sigma Z coefficient
and then I just plug it into my solver
and I find that the the optimum solution
is this so the thing the minimum l1 norm
X satisfying this is gives me a
robustness of root 2 and this is the
actual vector what it looks like so if
you can read off it actually make some
of this this and this in the right
proportions and you get a t stage
and this one here has a negative
coefficient right otherwise if these
were all positive would be a probability
distribution and we'll be inside the
octahedron okay so a nice thing about
linear programs is that while you're
solving this kind of minimization you're
also solving another problem at the same
time which is the dual problem so
effectively I'm maximizing the
expectation value with respect to some
kind of a witness operator and you know
when I eventually achieved the minimum
of my original problem than the dual
problem the solution of that is given me
a hyperplane which is the witness that's
tied against a set of stabilizer States
and so when I get the expectation value
of my state row with respect to this
witness that gives me exactly the
robustness so that's also a useful
feature so linear programs there are
actually very efficient to solve so
that's great in practice it's very easy
to do you just use CVX with matlab and
then this is literally one line of
syntax will solve the problem for you if
that's fine the only downside is that
the problem statement grows super
exponentially because the number of
stabilizer States grows super
exponentially in the number of qubits so
for a single qubit we had six vertices
for two qubits we have 60 vertices and
then by the time we got up to five
there's two and a half million columns
in our a matrix so that's where we
stopped
so now that I've set up the roast
robustness framework I'm gonna say how
we applied it in three different
scenarios so the first one is simulation
of quantum circuits so I'm gonna think
of a circuit composed of tifford gates
and t gates which as we heard in the
last talk is a universal quantum
computer so shouldn't be shouldn't
expect an efficient simulation scheme
otherwise we're all out of a job but our
result of that robustness gives you an
exponential simulation protocol with a
fairly okay exponent and this you know
scheme works for any third level
hierarchy type gate as we saw in the
last time can also apply this robustness
to get lower bounds on the number of key
gates for synthesizing certain circuits
and we also found some new or at least
to us kind of circuit identities that
were kind of surprising okay so the
first application simulation so basic
idea is that you take a quantum circuit
with tau of these t gates and every time
you see a TK you just replace it with
this gadget now we have a Clifford
circuit actually clifford circuit but
some of the inputs are magic states so
we're going to adapt the existing
schemes so that they can also work on
inputs that are just not stabilizer
States so there's going to be some magic
States as input as well so unfortunately
this is the third kind of definition of
robustness but they're all the same and
it's kind of useful to jump between the
different ones robustness is actually a
quasi probability distribution over
stabilizer States so what that means is
that these are X I weightings times the
each stabilizer state that gives you you
can decompose our state row in terms of
these stabilizer States and weightings X
I and these X I are going to sum to one
so that's that's a bit that's like a
probability but the fact that they can
be negative means they're
quasi-probabilities
so in our simulation scheme what we do
is we take that quasi-probability
representation and we just turn it into
a proper probability so you just take
the absolute value and then normalize
okay so now it's a proper probability
distribution and we can use
Chernov often type arguments to say that
we can simulate the circuit and it
requires this many samples to get Delta
close to the real distribution with
probability 1 minus Epsilon so what's
interesting here is that in our sample
complexity we see this quantity here
coming up which is exactly what we get
from robustness so the claim would be
that robustness has an operational
meaning as the classical simulation
overhead and so going back to the
original question if I have a circuit
with tau of these T type magic States we
get a simulation that scales as 1 point
6 8 5 to the power of tau to the power
of the so the number of T states that we
have and that compares quite well with
result from I think last year's qi p
bradley smith and small n where their
simulations game based on stabilizer
Schmitt rank had an exponent one point
one one point nine one nine ^ term so
where did I get this one point six eight
five number so we had that a circuit
using n copies of a resource state role
has simulation cost that goes there so
so how do we simulate a circuit with tau
of these TN sellers well the obvious
thing to do is just you know use the you
know just you use exactly this so would
be 2 to the tower scaling but the sub
multiplicative sub multiplicative 'ti
that I mentioned on the resource does it
read a list that actually is helpful
here so if instead we take chunks of T
State then we say that if we take two
copies and we take the square root then
we get a better scaling 1.74 aid if we
take three copies and you take the third
root then we get a better skinning again
and so on so again our numerix we could
go as far as five so that's where we got
this one point six
five number principle you could keep
going and going going and then where
does this finally end so the limit as n
goes to infinity so this would be the
regular eyes robustness of the nth root
of n fold copies of this T state is in
this interval between one point four
five seven to the town point six eight
five to the town so this is just the
five T State number that I was able to
calculate it explicitly this lower bound
comes from a theorem that we have in the
paper that to regularize robustness is
lower bounded so if you have a state
with block vectors or X or Y or Z then
we have a lower bound in terms of those
things so if you just plug in 1 over
root 2 for x and y here if you get that
one point four five seven over okay so
that was the simulation part now we're
going to talk about how can we use this
robustness to lower bound the number of
T gates for some synthesis so we are
going to have some circus it won't be
clifford plus t in general maybe maybe
it's got some control s gates in it so
we know already that there does exist
some decomposition of control s into
clifford plus t and this is what it
looks like but is this a good synthesis
or not so the basic idea that we can use
is okay we can take our gadget every
time you see a t gate just replace it
with this little gadget thing and then
because control s is from the third
level of the hierarchy this also has an
associated resource stage for magic
state which is just what you get by
applying control s to a plus state and
now we're going to compare the
robustness of this to the robustness of
these three qi gates
and because robustness is well-behaved
and it's not increasing under stabilizer
operations and so on we can see if we've
kind of wasted any of our t magic in
making this control last stage so it
turns out when you run the numbers that
this synthesis is actually really good
so the robustness of control s stage
lies in between two copies and three
copies of the T State and in fact it's
actually 2.2 which is very close to the
robustness of 3t states so this is
actually a very efficient use of magic
being parsimonious with our use of T
States okay
then took another example toughly it's
known for a few years now that the best
possible unitary synthesis of the tough
lay gate using clifford plus T requires
70 gates so you've got one two three
four five six seven that's truly optimal
but then Cody Jones comes along and he
says okay but if you just allow me to
use a couple of n sellers and do some
measurements then I can get it down to
four T gates those big saving and then
that's great that's good news but then
it's also but worrying how do we know
that there isn't some clever scheme that
uses more n sellers or measurements and
that we can do it safely with three
gates or two T gates or one T gate so to
put us out of our misery we apply the
resource theory of magic and we find
that the robustness of toughly is
sandwiched between three and four T
gates so for T gates is the minimum
possible that we could do even ancilla
assisted and so on so that's good and
I've cut off at the bottom here but in
our paper we have supplementary material
and appendices that show lots of
different optimality or non optimality
of kind of circuits like this
okay so that was the second application
the third application is what I'm
claiming are kind of surprising circuit
identities so this is equivalent to the
tough a this control control Z so for
the same reason as before we know that
the units recent says cost over the
Clifford plus T said of this gate is
seven we also know using the ami Musker
type stuff that are all talked about we
can simulate or we can synthesize this
cascaded control s's using four T gates
so these things can't be Clifford
equivalent obviously but if you just
look at the resource states associated
with these gates
these actually are actually four
equivalent so you know that's a little
bit surprising and so that gives you a
new way of implementing their toughly
gate with 40 gates you just synthesize
the state rather than the unitary and
then you do this generalized injection
that I'll talked about and you know we
knew to look for a clifford that would
take you from here to here because the
robustness of these two things is the
same
so this this example actually
generalizes so this is the tough hash
that are all discussed and here we have
caste cascaded control SS and for
exactly the same reason you see that T
cost of this thing is 11 t cost of this
thing is 8 but when you look at the
resource states they have the same
robustness and then you can actually
find an explicit cliff right that takes
you from one together so that gives you
a way of implementing this unitary using
age instead of 11 here's another one
that's a little bit surprising
this takes G cost 6 to implement this
takes T cos 5 the only difference is
this one has an extra T gate up here
it's not missing that's missing there
but the resource states are tifford
equivalent so we kind of we can
implement this using just 5 t gates so
we're getting this this guy up here for
free
final example said before that the
control ctrl Z costs 7 unit for
synthesizing unitarily for here on the
right we have controlled Eve where E is
at Clifford gate which is the one that
map's poly X to Y Y to Z and secretly
and so it's the one that has this state
that comes out through the face of the
octahedron as a fixed point which the
original bracket I have these were
called T States but we're trying to undo
history now and the new T states are
what me in a row talking about
they used to be called hate States but
anyway these two things obviously aren't
tifford equivalent of their different
tea costs but you can create the resort
state so this is effectively the gem of
Kowski state associated with the control
the operation here these two things are
equivalent equivalent and this is kind
of even a bit more surprising that
they're ones because this one isn't in
the third level of the covered hierarchy
okay so in summary protecting qubits
from Earth's incursion overhead and said
in some sense the Clifford stuff is easy
the tea gates are costly and so
naturally we have this resource theory
picture and we had the three
applications of this resource theory so
simulating quantum circuits explicit
simulation schemes that had overhead
that wasn't too bad
looking at optimality of circuit
synthesis using robustness and then this
what I said it's kind of surprising
different equivalents of magic States so
unfortunately I didn't get a chance to
mention all the other really good work
in this area so there's bravia Schmidt
and Smolin which I didn't mention this
bravi gossiped there is worked by Steve
Bartlett's group and there's worked by
the group in IQ C as well all on similar
topics here and the norm minimization
approach so this kind of ax equals B
type framework actually encompasses most
of these frameworks as well so you just
tweak it by saying okay we're trying to
minimize a different norm or we're gonna
kind of state the problem slightly
differently so for bradley smith and
small and they are doing the same kind
of minimization but now they're
minimizing the L naught norm because the
the Schmidt rank is the number of
stabilizer states that have nonzero
support and then for acute it's the
discreet Wigner function
the resource theory associated with that
is very successful and it turns out that
that fits in this game scheme as well
but now the the vertices of your free
region are these phase point operators
and so this free region is actually the
Wigner polytope instead of the
stabilizer polytope and so what was
known as some negativity in their
resource theory paper is actually just
the same as robustness okay so all these
results can be understood this way so
few open questions so I said we ran into
this super exponential kind of roadblock
in scaling up our our calculations so is
there some scalable way of calculating a
magic resource I think that would be
really useful or not I'm not sure how
you would go about that just yet here's
a measure that combines different
quantifiers possible or even preferable
so the bravi smith's mullen kind of
Schmitt rank approach that seemed to
find that T states were and amongst the
cheapest of the pure non stabilizer
States whereas we find them kind of
quite expensive within our robustness
picture so you know different
quantifiers they give you different
answers for what's expensive and what's
not is there some you know way of
comparing these things that means we
should choose one of the other maybe
ultimately it's what gives us the best
simulation scheme you know resource
theories in other fields like
entanglement
they have like results on asymptotic
inter convertibility and stuff like that
can we establish similar results here
and then finally just this relates to
these kind of surprising circuit
identities a lot of work
very good work has been put into the
unitary synthesis over the tifford plus
T basis but you know I said that
actually making the stage the resource
stage can cost a lot fewer T States than
synthesizing the unitary itself so can
we take some of this machinery and just
look and say calculate get some
algorithm for calculating the T cost for
creating these and sealers which should
be less than the unitary synthesis cost
okay so that's it thank you
thank you Mark so we have time for some
questions
hi how does this resource compared to
say the relative entropy from the
stabilizer palette up if you were just
give me an arbitrary state and ask for
the relative entropy from the palette oh
yes so a lot of these resource theory
type works you want to have a quantifier
that's that's well-behaved and so
robustness is one that appears in a lot
of and appears in a lot of papers and
relative entropy to the set of or yeah
the distance some distance type measure
to the set of free states is there as
well so we went for robustness surely
because of the ease of calculation it's
known that things like relative entropy
etc will you know obey all these good
properties in wants but in terms of
calculation I couldn't see that you know
scaling as well or getting the same
answers but so in terms of numbers I
don't know how they compare I can see
why you would use that and it kind of
may be more you know in a setting where
you weren't interested on just doing
numerix you wanted to prove things
analytically maybe you prefer this this
quantifier that you're talking about
we have a question back there
hi I'd like to ask for the Cinco cubed
case what I also wanna also states that
maximize your measure of robustness and
do they all belong to a single Clifford
group as a single a single orbit of the
under the preferred group this is the
state that's maximum a robust amongst
all single qubit States so I used to be
called the T State the old notation
let's come up with some new let's call
it the East a it anymore but yeah that's
the one that's most robust
there's a question like sir gain
I'm curious if you try to compute
robustness for noisy magic States and
try to apply your algorithm to simulate
noisy
quantum circuits the short answer is no
we didn't
I think depending on like if you had a
very simple noise model of just pure
depolarizing I think would be quite
simple - to figure that out I think it
would be a fairly simple you know
correction to the to the robustness that
we've calculated already thanks
Hey so did you say that I guess the
robustness ends up being the same as the
some negativity from the vigor function
resource theory exactly yeah okay so is
there a good easy reason to see why
maybe these results would have been
harder to come by using that resource
theory which has the same measure sorry
well so if both resources have the same
same resource measure with these results
that you have have been as easy to come
by and and see and get using just the
vigor function picture rather than all
right so the Wigner function works for
cute it's and so yeah you know that
right yeah yeah so you know you have
these funny properties of prime
dimensions that all Prime's are odd
except - which is the oddest of all so
you know when you run with that it turns
out that Wigner functions for multi
qubit systems are incredibly tricky and
complicated to work with whereas for
acute it's prime or power of prime
dimension where the prime is odd it's
very well behaved and yeah so the robust
the robustness there becomes the some of
the negative entries in your discrete
Wigner function and that's your that's a
well behaved monotone Thanks
so there's another question here yeah
hi so have you look at these circuits
that are immutable when you have low
robot glow robustness whether they are
where they are made non contextual
hidden variable models
[Music]
so I mean even if we even if we just
restricted ourselves to stabilizers
states they don't have non contextual
hidden variable models right so you have
states with small amounts of robustness
they could just be they would be by
definition just kind of Epsilon outside
the stabilizer polytope so you know if
your original scenario with just
stabilizer stuff is HUD doesn't have a
non contextual hidden variable model I
don't see why the the nearby stage that
has you know some of the resource in it
would be either
and Robert had a question
so I'm interested in this connection
with the world of rigna functions so
let's talk about queue let's say Q
traits so I thought in David grasses PhD
thesis there's an example of a state
with a positive Vigna function that is
not a probabilistic combination of
stabilizer States so it seems that if
you work in this big nerve function
picture more states are genuinely
classical then in the stabilizer picture
so my question is have you looked at say
Q traits specifically and have computed
the magic or your your robustness within
the stabilizer reference or with respect
to big nerd functions there are they're
more efficient simulation techniques
based on with big new functions if you
apply your measure so the the the
resource theory in full for the Wigner
function scenario has already done by
you know emerson and co but they they
didn't apply it specifically to this
question of simulation if that's what
you're talking about
so is there simulate for Q traits say is
there simulation more efficient
more fishing than what than yours if you
would apply yours to Q traits what so
I'm saying I mean you you have the
choice whether you want you can you can
choose the set of free stuff so if you
choose the set of free stuff to be the
stuff that's inside the Wigner polytope
then you get exactly the resource theory
that Veatch and emerson and so on have
yeah and how that scales for classical
simulation of some clifford posts
generalized tea circuit I don't know
okay didn't do that I didn't do that
yeah okay I'll use my privilege as a
chair to ask the last question so in the
simulation
I was wondering don't you need to
compute the vector X to perform the
simulation and can you do that
efficiently so that was this thing I had
about chunking it into so we have tau
tau copies of this T State and I said
I'm gonna break that down into chunks of
five each always and that's how we get
that one point six eight five saving
yeah all right well thank you again and
here's your Qi P t-shirt
[Applause]